if you were to find a pure sample of
hydrogen
odds are that the individual hydrogen
atoms in that sample aren't just going
to be separate atoms floating around
that many of them and if not most of
them would have bonded with each other
forming what's known as diatomic
hydrogen which we would not write as h2
another way to write it is you have each
hydrogen in diatomic hydrogen would have
bonded to another hydrogen to form a
diatomic molecule like this this
molecule is only made up of hydrogen but
it's two atoms of hydrogen and this
makes sense why it's stable because each
individual hydrogen has one valence
electron if it is neutral so that's one
hydrogen there that's another one there
and if they could share their variance
valence electrons they can both feel
like they have a complete outer shell
and so this dash right over here you can
view as a pair of electrons being shared
in a covalent bond
now we're going to do in this video is
think about the distance between the
atoms
so just as an example imagine two
hydrogens like this so that's one
hydrogen atom and that is another
hydrogen atom it turns out at standard
temperature pressure the distance
between the centers of the atoms
that we observe that distance right over
there is approximately 74 picometers and
just as a refresher of how small a
picometer is a picometer is 1 trillionth
of a meter so this is 74 trillionths of
a meter so we're talking about a very
small distance but one interesting
question is why is it this distance what
would happen if we tried to squeeze them
together what would happen if we tried
to pull them apart and to think about
that i'm going to make a little bit of a
graph that deals with potential energy
and distance
so in the vertical axis this is going to
be potential energy
potential
energy i won't give the units just yet
i'll just think in very broad brushed
conceptual terms and then we could think
about the units in a little bit
and then this over here is the distance
distance between the centers of the
atoms you could use the distance between
the nuclei and let's give this in
picometers
now potential energy when you think
about it's all relative to something
else and so let's just arbitrarily say
that at a distance of 74 picometers our
potential energy is right over here i'm
not even going to label this axis yet
now what's going to happen to the
potential energy if we wanted to pull
these two atoms apart
well this is what we typically find them
at this is probably a low point or this
is going to be a low point in potential
energy so if you make the distances go
apart you're going to put energy into it
and that makes the potential energy go
higher
and to think about why that makes might
send why that makes sense imagine a
spring right over here if you want to
pull it apart if you pull on either
sides of a spring
you are putting energy in which
increases the potential energy because
if you let go they're just going to come
back to they're going to they're going
to accelerate back to each other so as
you pull it apart you're adding
potential energy to it so as you have
further and further distances between
the nuclei the potential energy goes up
and if you go really far it's going to
asymptote towards some value and that
value is essentially going to be the
potential energy if these two atoms were
not bonded at all if they to some degree
weren't associated with each other if
they weren't interacting with each other
and so that's actually the point at
which most chemists or physicists or
scientists would label zero potential
energy the energy at which they are
infinitely far away from each other and
that's what this is asymptoting towards
and so let me just draw that line right
over here so let's call this
zero
right over here and actually let me now
give units let's say all of this is in
kilojoules per mole
now once again if you're pulling them
apart as you pull further and further
and further apart you're getting closer
and closer to these these two atoms not
interacting why is that because as you
get further and further and further
apart the coulomb forces between them
are going to get weaker and weaker and
weaker and weaker and so that's why they
like to think about that as zero
potential energy
now what if we think about it the other
way around what if we want to squeeze
these two together well once again if
you think about a spring if you imagine
a spring like this just as you would
have to add energy or increase the
potential energy of the spring if you
want to pull the spring apart
you would also have to do it to squeeze
the spring more and so to get these two
atoms to be closer and closer and closer
together you have to add energy into the
system and increase the potential energy
and why why are you having to put more
energy into it because the more that you
squeeze these two things together you're
going to have the positive charges of
the nuclei repelling each other so
you're gonna have to try to overcome
that and that puts potential energy into
the system and these electrons are
starting to really overlap with each
other and they will also want to repel
each other
and so what we've drawn here this is
just conceptually is this idea of if you
wanted them to really overlap with each
other you're going to have a pretty high
potential energy and if you're going to
have them very separate from each other
you're not going to have as high of a
potential energy but this is still going
to be higher than if you're at this
stable point the stable point is stable
because that is a minimum point it is a
low point in this potential energy graph
you could view this as just right and it
turns out that for diatomic hydrogen
this difference between zero and where
you will find it at standard temperature
and pressure this distance right over
here is 432 kilojoules per mole so this
is at the point negative 432 kilojoules
per mole and so one interesting thing to
think about a diagram like this is how
much energy would it take to separate
these two atoms to completely break this
bond would be the energy of completely
pulling them apart and so it would be
this energy it would be this energy
right over here or 432
kilojoules and that's what people will
call the bond energy the energy required
to separate the atoms
and we'll see in future videos the
smaller the individual atoms and the
higher the order of the bonds so from a
single bond to a double bond to a triple
bond the higher order of the bonds the
higher of a bond energy you're going to
be dealing with